[Musica]
tranquilla ti svegli più tardi molto più
tardi
adesso pensa solo a dormire ninna nanna
ninna questa bimba chi la donna non ce
la farò mai a studiare tutto questo
libro per domani con calma allora amo è
da dieci minuti che non stalker i crack
su instagram
ma non mi distrarre per favore non mi
tentare non posso votare e allora
guardano video di marina ma l'ho già
visto quindi basta è ora di studiare
e allora karaoke arianna massai anni to
be allora risotto cielo la cipolla pure
faccio soffitto con le carote fresche e
qualcosa cosa stai facendo è stata la
cucina yoga c'è un bel risottino
insegnerebbe tu che hai goccini fidati
di me fatti questa bella gruppo in busta
di quelle chimiche che ti lasciano
l'amaro in bocca per due tre giorni
che schifo per visco le cose naturali
amore ma questa la fa in soli due minuti
[Musica]
ma sei pazza perché devi rifare il letto
se tanto poi lo devi riusare ci pensiamo
poi dai dai
ok è la e questa tenuta ginnica e devo
andare in palestra ei tuoi in palestra
ti giuro mi sono iscritto a un mese fa e
devo andare se non butto via i soldi ma
forse dimentichi che hai comprato questo
bellissimo tappetino per allenarti in
casa dove nessuno ti disturba nessuno ti
guarda cosa fa più caldo
foglio rosa allora cosa biscotto
parallel sistemare sistemare ma i
disordini a bello un senso guarda tutto
colorato effettivamente molto artistico
e se il sistema allora cosa facciamo
non lo so guardiamo la nuova puntata di
riverdale d'oro fate bono arci non hai
capito perché ti ho scoperto che il mio
fidanzato
scusate se stai facendo con quella scopa
in mano
secondo te devo pulire questa stanza fa
schifo ma riscoprì non servono per
pulire sono di fantastici microfoni di
me che tenne moschea si sta con 96
sbagliando ciao io vado buona serata no
scusa dove vai
e vada bene con i miei mi che perché
perché tra poco inizia diluvio
universale ci rovinerà i capelli di
colera il trucco per non parlare del
fatto che domani ti svegli con
l'influenza
invece se rimaniamo qua a casa sotto la
copertina con una bella cioccolata calda
magari a guardare netflix domani ti
sveglierai fresca come una rosa
ok però la cioccolata calda la fai tu
cosa guardiamo di serata struccarsi però
stanca e chi l'ha detto che bisogna
struccarsi c'è questo così tanto fare
questo make up tienitelo dove dormire e
domani sempre i fondi telethon si troppo
innovativa mi sveglio con la pelle tutta
eccitata perché non respira perché poi
chiarito precoce io sono tutte le
leggende metropolitane non è mai morto
nessuno
[Musica]